le nous revenons à présent dans cette
émission sur l'une des principales
informations politiques de la semaine
dans les yvelines et c'est avec wilfrid
rieschick et m'a rejoint en plateau
rédacteur en chef de tv 78 bonjour
wilfried bonjour grégory nous allons
nous arrêter à tra pour vous le savez
les élections municipales ont finalement
été annulées par le conseil d'état qui a
jugé illégal je cite des actions de
propagande menée par le vainqueur du
scrutin ali rabais et c'était à la fin
du mois d'août la nouvelle élection aura
lieu en octobre alors pourquoi en parler
maintenant tout simplement parce qu'un
coup de théâtre vient de rythmer cette
campagne l'ancien maire de gauche de la
commune entre 2001 et 2020 guy malandain
a annoncé une alliance avec le
conseiller régional d'ile-de-france lieu
ce nom de valérie pécresse othman nassr
ou une situation qui interpelle jusque
dans les plus hautes sphères nationales
hier jean luc mélenchon y est allé de
son tweet pour commenter à la situation
il demande à anne hidalgo de condamner
l'alliance du ps et de la droite alors
pourquoi une telle alliance vous allez
me le demander et bien tout simplement
un petit rappel l'an dernier ali rabais
ancien adjoint de guy malandain protégés
de benoît hamon décide de se présenter
aux élections sous l'étiquette de
génération et guy malandain est un
ancien membre du parti socialiste ils
crient à la trahison il brigue lui aussi
un nouveau mandat après dix neuf ans à
la tête de la commune il n'arrive qu'à
la troisième place derrière othman
nasrullah campagne a été violence
tensions entre les anciens alliés
tension aussi avec les autres candidats
on se souvient ici du débat difficile
que nous avions organisée entre eux
voilà comment à guy malandain justifie
son alliance avec othman nasro
aujourd'hui nous formons une liste
républicaine
démocratique et honnête nous sommes
trois têtes de liste si je puis dire en
10 malandain pèse ses mots on entend les
mots république un honnête cette
nouvelle campagne jusqu'au scrutin qui
se tiendra le rappellent les 10 et 17
octobre s'annonce donc haut tout aussi
virulent tinqueux que l'année dernière
autant virulente c'est effectivement
dans qu'on puisse dire une nouvelle
étape a même été franchie avec la
publication d'un article de valeurs
actuelles intitulé incurie clientélisme
communautarisme enquêtes et révélations
sur le maire déchu de trappes pendant
son court passage finalement en tant que
maire ali rabais est accusé de népotisme
de favoritisme de clientélisme de
communautarisme est les témoignages sont
anonymes mais viendrait aussi bien de
ses proches que de ses ennemis écoutez
le journaliste auteur de cette enquête
amour bruit on a été contacté il ya déjà
plusieurs mois par des personnels
municipaux et à partir de là donc nous
avons creusé nous avons contacté plus
d'une trentaine de personnes
donc à la fois personnels municipaux et
élus locaux des deux bords évidemment
qui nous ont donc raconter les coulisses
de ce mandat l'écrasante majorité des
personnes et qui ont accepté de nous
répondre ont refusé quand les sites
qu'on donne leur nombre encore moelleux
le poste qu'ils occupent au sein de la
mairie
que ça de l'employé de base jusqu'aux
cadres supérieurs
avec un climat de terreur à la mairie et
qui se poursuit aujourd'hui qui
s'aggrave depuis d'ailleurs les pinots
révélation à dirab est mis en accusation
n'a pas répondu au journal non mais son
équipe a publié un communiqué sur les
réseaux sociaux sur facebook son équipe
parle de calomnies de mensonges qui
viennent alimenter un journal d'extrême
droite obsédé par les musulmans le grand
remplacement qui fait la promotion
d'eric zemmour et de marine le pen voilà
pour cet extrait de tracts distribués à
trappes othman nasri est accusée
d'alimenter ce climat de tension voici
sa réponse moi je n'ai pas besoin
d'alimenter qui que ce soit puisque ce
sont notamment beaucoup d'agents tally
rabelais a maltraité qui ont parlé à
valeurs actuelles c'est écrit dans
l'article beaucoup qui sont partis moi
je n'étais pas témoin des scènes qui ont
été rapportés j'aurais été bien
incapable d'ailleurs de lire à porter
quand il dit à un agent le licenciant
qui a une place au cimetière j'étais pas
très bien cette discussion cet agent est
parti il a raconté à valeurs actuelles
il a raison de faire et nos clients un
moment il faut qu'on retrouve à trappes
de l'apaisement de la sérénité du
rassemblement qu'on arrête de tout
politiser qu'on arrête cette brutalité
cette agressivité qu'on a beaucoup vu à
la télévision aussi si on veut améliorer
l'image de la ville il faut de la
sérénité il faut travailler sérieusement
sur les dossiers qui n'avancent pas
depuis un an et les électeurs
trancheront dans les urnes qu'on arrête
de vouloir intimider les uns et les
autres à lire à bas n'a pas souhaité non
plus de répondre alors pas sur ce sujet
nous avons échangé par sms il a décidé
en tout cas ne pas avoir encore décidé
s'il pourrait être porterait plainte
pardon contre le journal pour
diffamation et prendra sa décision après
le scrutin il m'a aussi à préciser qu'il
ne voulait pas tomber dans le piège de
ses adversaires est tirée la campagne
vers le bas
il ajoute aussi que les médias sérieux
devrait hisser le débat au bon niveau je
précise tout de même que nous avions
souhaité organiser un débat sur ce
plateau à lire à bell lui n'a pas
souhaité y participer pour jeu réussit
une nouvelle fois ne pas donner de la
respectabilité un candidat qui le dit
femmes un dernier élément portés à notre
connaissance ce vendredi wilfried et qui
vient confirmer ce climat tendu à
trappes c'était juste avant de débuter
cette édition c'est l'avocat de rogatien
bouchereau qui est aujourd'hui est le
directeur de campagne d'ali rabais il
nous informe avoir saisi le procureur de
la république par l'intermédiaire de son
avocat pour menaces de mort des menaces
qui auraient été prononcés par des
militants politiques d'opposition
identifié on n'en sait pas beaucoup plus
pour l'instant tout cas vous l'avez dit
le climat est particulièrement tendue et
pendant ce temps il ya toujours 70%
d'abstentionnistes à travail